hey guys I'm so excited because today we
are heading into hangout Andrew and Matt
from the drone dude so you guys know me
or seen any my videos I am absolutely
obsessed with drones
so that part about this video today is
it's a VR video so take a look around
you're going to be getting an entire
immersive view of everything that I'm
saying so let's head inside and see some
drone they're way cooler than anything
that I have alright so I'm hanging out
Andrew and Matt thank you guys so much
for chatting with me today so right now
what we're looking at and that's drone
we've got the goggles yeah indeed we do
we've got the inspire one Pro X I draw
here this is one of our workforces that
drones use we use just a lot on smaller
commercial car commercial anything where
you got to be fast and tracking we like
this tone a lot this is piloting pilot
alright let's pick this thing up here we
go
one of the most difficult things is
flying a drone and operating a camera at
the same time so this is great because
you can do both with two people one
drone two dudes one drone
l.joe
I think one of the misconceptions - is
drones don't just have to be in the air
what do you have that over here yeah cuz
I could take a look so this is a this is
a land-based drone and this is a free
fly system taro this is a an RC car
where we mount a variety of different
cameras onto this platform which is as
you can see it's stabilized with these
Springs and it's just a really cool
rover sized platform that gets their
unique low angle tracking shot yeah
that's awesome
now these headsets that we have here how
does this all work that is basically
will connect to that so you can fly
through that instead of using the iPad
yeah this is this is just a VR headset
it has the ability to put phone into it
and with the motion tracker with your
head you can literally strap on the
goggles and pilfers fly and your pile
will take it up and you can look around
as if here in the camera wow you're
actually in the drone itself that's
something I have not tried yet so I'm
super excited about that but it's cool
computing into our video here so where
do you see VR sort of going in the drone
space is that something a lot of people
is doing with 360 I think you know as I
move into the future you know drones
really have that have a great effect of
getting wide shot getting out there so
with 360 video you're going to have to
find a happy medium range and I think
with flying drones through interesting
areas like the Hollywood sign for
example or maybe volcano or something
interesting you're going to get close
and see the lots of cool things
happening that's where we are going to
go the terminal side awesome well thank
you guys so much
yeah